[Music]
Northwest seems to be following right in
her famous mom's footsteps oh wow
shocked here's a look at seven times Kim
Kardashian's mini-me has totally stolen
the show with her cuteness wedding five
today honey they're going to Wed ignore
this girl clearly Northeast the life of
a wedding party
[Music]
but even this little diva can be camera
shy
why don't you want what no one no
pictures what move over Kim Kourtney and
khloé there's another face [ __ ] pro in
town here's north and her bestie Ryan
having a blast with the snap chat
feature sometimes little nori has a
difficult time trying to
[Music]
the adorable tot clearly had some
precious cargo in her frozen suitcase
during this trip to the airport its
cuteness overload
every time North hangs out with her
cousin Penelope Disick I love that these
two are so close they even feel each
other's pain they like the song and Kim
and Kanye's little one has the side-eye
down but North biggest show-stealing
moment hello my only one just like the
Morning Sun nothing tops nuria's
appearance in her daddy's music video
for only one
[Music]
you